c'est l'équipe de france de la coupe du
monde des u17 à laquelle manu a assisté
manu ici présents sur place donc c'était
à malaga
je t'entends pas manu tu es en mieux
il ya également luca qui est ici nous
nouveaux membres alors vous l'avez déjà
vu dans notre live sur français mais
voilà nouveau membre officiel de
l'équipe savalou cas
ça ça va très bien un premier live en
tant que
ça fait plaisir pas le dernier non pas
le dernier c'est
très bien et il ya bien sûr mon hugues
certains qui est qui et la mi-ombre me
lumière tu vas bien
exact bah ouais c'est cool ça va ça va
ça va j'essaie de prouver ma peau 1 pour
un petit peu de temps donc on y va
doucement
salue l'équipe dans le chat on vous
avait pas tease et le live donc voilà on
a décidé de le faire comme ça un peu
dernier moment on va faire un bilan de
cette coupe du monde u17 pour l'équipe
de france uniquement donc c'est assez
précis et on s'est réparti les joueurs
et on va aller assez vite sur certains
joueurs évidemment mais on va passer en
revue les 12 membres de l'équipe de
france manu quand tu veux tu réessaie de
parler pour voir si je t'entends ya pas
de problème
ma nuque et qu'ils étaient donc sur
place on avait en avait nié qu on avait
un lan qui étaient là bas c'était
rachetant toujours pas montmagny
on commence alors attendez je reprends
le fils que je vous avais envoyé
messieurs on va commencer par les
barrières hockey et on va commencer luca
j'étais perdue en vidéo mais on va
commencer avec que kilian maloyas
killian maloyas à chaque fois vous allez
faire un petit bio rapide et puis
ensuite on va réagir sur vraiment la
performance sur ce cd m17 est ce qu'on
peut attendre pour l'avenir di luca qui
voyagent en m 1,17 qui joua gt on voit
depuis un bon moment
et qui vient de moi en aval et c'est un
poste qui est cette année
quand même pas mal gagnant hype après la
santé avec manu on a pu constater
tout son portrait
il a développé cette année un bon shoot
à trois points quantiques et de plus en
plus correct on apprend après bien sûr
pendant pendant la campagne
mais oui c'est 1,5 et qui est beaucoup
plus
intéressant en off ball qui a été une
grosse menace au football et je vais pas
aller plus loin avant qu'on en parle
mais
bacchetti rôle
j'ai le son qui sautent chez toi ou cas
décidément on n'est pas verni pour pour
ce début de transmission maintenu
n'ont toujours pas
aujourd'hui exceptionnel
c'est terrible parce que là on va pas
pouvoir faire de transmission s'y
essayer de couple essaye de couper la
vidéo luca pour voir si ça si c'est le
flux qui prend pas le sens que ça
faisait des coupures en fait donc qu'il
ya de mal wyeth l'espace 2 3 1 plus pose
de trois athlétique
que se trouve beaucoup plus intéressant
emmena softball ou
oui des découpes ligne de front qui qui
sont ambitieux nantes à voir ouais et il
a développé de plus en plus son tir à
trois points plus qu'intéressante
vraie pression sur le cercle hugues
quelle qu'elles quel rôle on va donner à
ce joueur en pro en tout cas sur ses
premières années comment comment on va
développer maloyas
je pense qu'on va commencer par le
montant que attaquants jason ça va être
un jour qui n'aura pas je pense la
direction de culte du jeu balle en main
au départ
qui va vraiment être dans le
renversement qui m'a ce trouble à 3,2
points
qui va attendre que les défenses monde
sur lui pour attac quelque chose qui va
exploser auxerre qui va vraiment occupés
on est sur des joueurs si on veut
comparer avec eux pour lui l'espoir
c'est comme la nba je pense que c'est
pas irréaliste de penser que ça peut
être un prospect nba en tout cas il est
quand même eu assez suivi et à ses
premiers là dessus on peut avoir un
joueur qui suit la draft de cette année
à mais comme les eaux chaudes badji
les mecs comme john wood des choses
comme ça et les souris ndi et avec une
bretonne de le développer nos bas n'est
pas tout ce pôle est
le cas on est sur des mensurations
similaire est ce qui va encore grandir
et ce qui va encore s'épaissir aussi
quel genre de le physique c'est au
manoir
j'aime pas prendre ce multi c'est sur ce
qu'il est il assez fin quand même
aujourd'hui
mais il en a pas tant à gagner en
prendre plus que ça car dès ce ce corps
athlétique
permettent quand même de monter pas mal
aussi pertes on n'a pas pu le voir
beaucoup de set qu'il a pas mal gêné
mais ouais je pense tu vas y a moyen qui
prennent encore il fait déjà un mais
quatre ans 17 donc aussi prend un ou
deux centimètres se ramasse rogers
way we pour arriver dans ses
mensurations qui augment sionnel et agb
gillet williams r savoir aux environs
des deux mètres
et au niveau de la longueur en tu as tu
as ta son envergure non j'ai pas réussi
à trouver son envergure
il aimait mais plutôt l'on visite en
défense on le vend tout cas j'ai peur
des interceptions elles sont d'envergure
un réel problème en défense
l'a vu à belgrade pas de menu peut
contraindre bon
sortie de de loin son envergure est
reliant défense et c'est un gros plus
pour nous
manu est ce qu'on entend est ce que tu
nous en moi je vous entends à saillé
attentant killian maria bals super
killian maloyas toi tu étais sur place
donc je disais qu'est ce que tu as ont
tiré sûr pour l'attitude et comment il
faut le développer maintenant dans quel
contexte il faut le mettre pour
justement
si là il verse ce haut niveau et
l'espoir peut-être d'une draft nba joe
balaÿ lydia il était utilisé pas mal en
sortie de banc quasiment tout le temps
il est sorti du banc et abus est mille
fois titulaire contre le canada su me
rappelle bien et en fait il n'ya jamais
qu il sortait du vol n'est jamais rentré
dans son match et j'ai toujours du mal à
trouver son rôle dans l'équipe et du
coup ça a été des il a fait des matches
chuta il ya pas un match référence
finalement il ya toujours eu du mal ou
si peut-être que le japon mais qu'est ce
qu'on peut retenir du japon c'est c'est
compliqué on savait qu il allait les les
casser en deux et c'est ce qui s'est
passé et du coup c'est soit sur sur
l'attitude c'est plus ça c'est vraiment
rentré dans ces matches qui a toujours
eu du mal après il a fait ce qu'on
attend de lui sur tout rebond il a été
impressionnant au rebond offensif
notamment où il est quasiment à deux
prises par match sur sur le tournoi
notamment 4 / / match contre l'espagne
et ses effets c'est vraiment que c'est
pas son go to move mais c'est vraiment
quelque chose d'impressionnant quand on
voit sur le terrain bon dirigeant il va
très très très haut ils ont très très
vite au cirque il a pas besoin de
beaucoup d'élan non plus pour pour
prendre l'aventage il a le nez un peu
comme avec kevin love dans ses belles
années il a toujours de l'avant c'est
peut-être un millième de seconde il a
toujours cette avance là et que ce soit
face à démarrera par exemple contre
l'espagne ils arrivent quand même à
titiller et à choper les robots comme ça
c'était vraiment impressionnant sur le
robot rov pas trop en réussite sur le
trois points je pense que c'est la clé
de son entrée en nba c'est son tir là il
n'a pas vraiment été en on a réussi là
23% sur la trois points 3 sur 13
donc c'est un peu décevant mais j'ai pu
les quatre sur les 1 100 m haies 1 c'est
un peu plus que ça j'aurais de tête mais
ça ils tentent donc c'est par ali tente
après c était dans plus dans la rue le
spacing cétacés des fois un peu qu'on
ait laissé le sens vers l'axé bagnols
pour moi ouais clairement parce qu'après
le va pas forcément lui demander
d'initiés ou quoi je pense pas mais si
vraiment ça ce que ce qu'ils disaient
les nougats et ux et un potentiel
qui va dorénavant et des limites mois
pour débloquer ces qualités de deux
doigts finition auxerre qu il va falloir
c'est vraiment ça qui doit doit
travailler
plus que plus que s'orienter du coup
vers un profil avec + + wolhandler lui
ça sera ce sera vraiment plus à un
slasher et vous il faut pas trop enfin
il faut pas toujours bien d'avoir du
haendel mais je veux dire dans l'idée ça
va pas être un joueur comme ça luca
d'être plus à l'iss la charge doit robe
de troupes ouais je le trouve beaucoup
au début de l'année ils ont
il a pas il a pas mal de développeurs
au niveau du bowler bamber et sais pas
mais je trouve ce problème qui est vous
pour le très haut niveau
il le trouvera beaucoup plus dans une
nasse un jeu qui peut
qui tranche qui tue tulle tulle h 2
secondes et il va donner sur toi ouais
on passe à la suite messieurs et c'était
lui qui va nous présenter le jeune qui
truste
qui tu joues à strasbourg kehl profil
montluc pour piétrus qui étaient
parfois titulaire parfois il sortait du
banc ça manuelle
ou a globalement été titulaire comme way
et l'udc avaient plus des minutes de
temps de jeu mais on
m'a dit vas-y le
tueur habitait dans le dans les
commentaires
on a des petits bottes
ilan piétrus du coup fils florent
piétrus en assam français qu'on connaît
bien qu'il lui du coup je joue à
strasbourg tu l'as dit j'aurais terme
ans avec les jeunes il a fait quelques
piges en quelques petits matchs avec
l'équipe professionnelle
mais c'est vraiment à ça les petits
cantons de droite est faible
majoritairement on a un joueur qui
fait un mètre 80 8 1 m 89 d'après les
mensurations
les mensurations excuse-moi lnb et si
barry un joueur qui semble physiquement
assez
fini que ce soit musculairement que ce
soit dans la dans la taille c'est une
des interrogations qu'on a le plus se
retrouver parler des observateurs sur
place et en extérieur c est ce que ce
pour encore grandir est donc née de la
maturité et il ya plutôt des doutes là
dessus mais c'est pas du tout ma
spécialité donc c'est vraiment une
question que je vais lancer et après
dans le profil de jeu rapide on est sur
un bo l'un de leurs quasiment exclusif
qui a montré avec l'équipe française des
difficultés loin du ballon montré qu'ils
avaient besoin d'avoir la balle qui a
montré qu'il avait besoin de prendre des
tirs peut prendre des décisions et qu'on
est plus sur un profil d'attaquant de
bons moments quand vrai abrets bon shoot
est notamment derrière les noms
mais après il est capable de mettre des
tirs difficiles où mm est pas avec une
grande efficacité
on va dire ça comme ça ce soir
[Musique]
non je voulais vraiment lent que
lens et manu tu relâches défense de
dylan et russe
ce perdant pas son point fort il est
intéressant mais c'est clairement pas
son point fort d'envergure et pas de
fold à la taille malheureusement il est
bloqué à 1 88 donc là il fait quasiment
certain qui va plus grandir donc c'est
vraiment ça y est après la panne est il
intéressant mais c'est pas c'est pas son
point fort il est le cas parce que
[Musique]
je t'entends pas pardon avec la sig il
joue à strasbourg il était sur des
missions défensives cette année quand il
quand ils allaient jouer avec les grands
luca
je trouve que ce qui est bien avec lui
c'est que ça c'est un peu un double
tranchant mais et c'est un peu faim
j'ai vu des flashs cette année ou
ou même en vain énormément d'intensité
en défense ils pourrissent et un peu son
vis-à-vis et je pense à 100 de dieu est
avec son vis-à-vis pour vraiment même en
défense on sent venir le monde lui venir
à lui prendre des balles mais ont ils
fait pas son ton arc principal on va
dire
ouais ça complique un peu la donne je
pense qu'il faut je sais pas si ça pour
coup pour vous dites nous dans le chat
s'il entendait bien de cas ou pas mais
rejetant voir
c'est parfois il ya des mots qui saute
et du coup je suis obligé de faire un
effort pour rompre la phrase alors que
on sent que tu as bien vu les matchs de
phase i je rejoins ce qu'il disait sur
le côté du lc leurs écouteurs un joueur
qui est acté les prix ce tout-terrain
homme qui a été moindre en efficacité
car un autre défenseur comme lama ou
pichard mais qui a vraiment fait des
prises tout terrain sauf que ils se
mobilisent dans ce duel et se fait
prendre sur des changements de vitesse
sur des changements de direction un peu
trop simple à mon goût dans leur pick
and roll dont les pros il est impliqué
mais là mon coach l'a dit yannick par
exemple j'ai vu un jeu par qui se
faisait passer sur des premiers pas
assez classique juste parce que
l'attaquant ne prenait pas l'écran et le
feinter voilà ces îles on l'attend
encore et ça manque de preuves c'est au
classement plus que 2 jusque 2 de
physique on va dire enfin de latéralité
quoi je pense
donc qu ilan piétrus manu si on donne
quelques ailes plafond les observateurs
sur place et toi et compris est ce qu'on
a en retirer de cette compétition pour
ces prochaines années et qu'est ce que
c'est son plafond
sa marge de progression est surtout sur
la capacité sur sa capacité à faire
jouer les autres c'était un amoureux du
ballon ils le gardent beaucoup beaucoup
et c'est moi c'est ce qui me gêne un peu
c'est que ce soit avec l'équipe de
france ou strasbourg avec les espoirs il
l'a jamais trop montré qu'ils pouvaient
le faire il ya quelques petits flashs là
il ya quatre passes décisives je crois
de moyenne mais c'est c'est beaucoup sur
la transition du aliou peut donc
finalement c'est pas c'est pas énorme
sur sur du jeu placé il sait qu'il sait
pas le faire il peut plus ils arrivent
ils arrivent pas à faire jouer son
équipe ça c'est vraiment dommage c'est
moi c'est la plus grosse marge de
progression avec sa sélection de tirs
parce qu' il peut tirer on est tous dans
tous les sens ya pas de souci son gros
point fort mais faut juste qu'ils
sélectionnent c'est cher quoi parce que
des fois ça peut être vraiment
problématique on a un exemple sur les
u18 fine fort dé 8,8 là où on était avec
alan ou sur le match contre cholet il
fait n'importe quoi honnêtement ils
peuvent le gagner mais quand il doit
prendre 7 shoots sur la halle sur les
deux dernières minutes il en est pas un
coin et ainsi perdre alors comment il
est et il est très rude à coude et
finalement il fait perdre son équipe eq
c'est vraiment la sélection tirer le
l'initiation pour les autres vraiment de
la création pour les optiques y va c'est
sa porte d'entrée pour avoir dix minutes
dans le devenir et c'est pour ça que je
préfère honnêtement sur ce passage en
pro même si c'était très court mais on
sentait qu'il avait plus un rôle oui du
coup il était un peu plus efficace ouais
un problème de maturité 1 dans ce que
j'entends ce que vous dites ça placement
défensif pas un problème mais je dire
une question de maturité ces choses qui
peuvent venir on parle de joueurs qui
sont nés en 2005 donc si on parle draft
nba y seront exigibles en 2024
nous allons passer manu je reste avec
que toi pour la présentation de fib
laïque a été le la révélation il est
dans le cinq du tournoi pas de bêtises
wade a clairement là la surprise du
tournoi pour cette équipe de france
c'est pas un un jour qu'on attendait
donc c'est un poste un deux voire trois
cas annoncés 1,95 petite voix qui vous
pour le france à l'insep
il
est sorti beaucoup du banc sur sur cette
compétition et c'est un genre qui a
surpris énormément parce que sur l'insep
c'était l'équipe dorian roux pertes dont
il n'avait pas forcément beaucoup de la
balle il avait un rôle vraiment bien
défini alors que là avec l'équipe de
france baïla il a mis dedans il a montré
qu'il était très athlétique pas beau pas
besoin de beaucoup d'élan pour aller au
paléo junkie coupe bien et il a mis
dedans à 3 points donc c'est vraiment
super intéressant il à 61% à 3 points
quand même sur le sur le tournoi 8 sur
avec des tentatives par match donc il a
il a impressionné honnêtement les gens
qui étaient là ce soit les scouts où les
nba ou les équipes universitaires
il a beaucoup impressionné beaucoup
venaient nous en parler quand on était à
côté deux genres vous le connaissez d'où
il vient et où donc c'était assez
intéressant de le voir taper dans l'oeil
comme ça surtout quand on connaît un peu
plus et qu'on l'a vu sur la saison où là
il est transformé c'est pas du tout le
même joueur quoi il m'a vraiment surpris
surpris et du coup l'année prochaine ses
records insead pour lui willan c'est un
vrai parce que cette année pour la
veille il faut dire il faut dire aussi
qu'il avait peut-être un rôle un peu
moins donc l'insep qui joue face à des
joueurs de n1 général wayne rooney et
ses d'année ryan rupert avait un an de
plus que lui donc c'est aussi pour ça
qu'il avait plus la balle etc
une rumeur qui sera au bout en
championnat australien
et donc la lune cette qu'il ya beaucoup
de personnes qui sans like qui ont fort
mal et donc
and haas 3
pén d'ajinça rupert on sera de musi 10
ans va aussi donc ça ça peut le
libérer voir ça fait intéressant de voir
ce qui ce qui va être fait de lui ce qui
va être la première option est ce qu'il
va être le porteur de balle principal de
l'attak sont avec l'installation de le
voir ça va être l'année pour voir si
c'est plus un porteur de balle peu ou si
c'est plus d'un maloyas dont on parlait
au début il confiant que ce qu'on a vu
que ce soit dans le foot ou bien souvent
dans la carte du cercle vraiment
ça va être avoir
une quel profil athlétique tu as vu est
ce que c'est un mal ouallal maloyas like
dont on parlait au début c'est à dire
slasher
silva fort au cercle qui accepte bien
contacter moi j'ai trouvé
je trouve que mal voyait plus smooth
après ces visuels que plus félin
s'ils veulent moi je tu vas chercher
leur premier match je connaissais pas du
tout genre donc j'ai vu le premier match
et je vois un petit prend beaucoup les
tirs quoi qui prend la balle et qui sait
de ce corps et je me suis dit oh la la
c'est quoi ce c'est quoi ce profil il
m'appelle pas kiffer sur le début est en
fait au fur et à mesure de la
compétition je pense qu'il a pris
confiance en lui il a vu que le staff
allait pas lui lui interdire de prendre
le ballon et je les trouvais de plus en
plus propres donc ouais un joueur qui a
montré qu'ils pouvaient marquer toutes
les distances qui était agressif
effectivement qui qui prenait bien le
contact
je pense pas qu'on en fera forcément un
porteur de balle n'ont pas à avoir un
profil de scoreur en fixation et j'aime
bien donc je vais je vais suivre plus
l'année prochaine être un peu plus sur
le dossier il était de refaire l'erreur
de découvrir une ce numéro 10 qui qui
met des gros shoots
effectivement luca s pour finir pour toi
c'est quoi le la chose à travailler pour
ilan bluy
c'est comme l'a dit comme l'a dit manu
et puis ça peut être un beau l'ampleur
pendant
30 minutes à lire comme comme l'a dit m
mais beaucoup de gens parlent de l'insep
donc on verra si c'est l'heure de deux
de l'attak
et mais je le trouve vraiment et est un
peu plus
qu'un peu plus similaire à maloyas dans
cette meneuse surgir un peu un peu nulle
part' mettre un coup de bach
c'est
sa coupe toujours douces ouais ouais ça
coupe toujours on a qu'on accomplit à
peu près 30 tournée filet on va voir
mais mais on va essayer de messages sais
pas si tu peux déconnecter reconnecter
voir
mettre des écouteurs je sais pas comment
tu peux fermer mais en l'occurrence
c'est un peu compliqué pour on enchaîne
on enchaîne s'il vous plaît avec je les
ai mis ensemble parce que dit-on qui
s'était moins visibles
il avait mal à l'ipod prospects dont on
parle même si c'est pas du tout le même
genre de joueur
donc pichard et là bas ça va un peu
groupe autre chose certaine ça fait du
yo d'humoristes des années 80 tu vois
mais
dès du coup à toi qui sais qu'il devait
présenter pichard sétois hughes ouais
ouais
théo pichard dit s'attendre à l'esam
fédéral joueur qui fait 80 buts assez de
développer déjà physiquement
c'était un peu le monsieur propre
l'équipe globalement ilan petrus
commencé avec sa folie balle en main et
puis ensuite voulu un peu plus temporisé
m de la vraie défense l'homme est un peu
moins de gratuite en attaque on faisait
rentrer tôt car c'est un joueur qui a un
grand frère mon pichard qui est aussi
passé par le centre de formation à
l'épreuve à jouer en pro
en france j'ai pu essayer de la pro b ou
de la jpc que le grand frère clément va
à passer professionnel
c'est un mec à ce que je me suis dit
voilà qui kiffe le basket pour l'instant
et qui a dit mme moi ce que je veux
c'est une opportunité de jouer donc lui
qui le dit si les deux trois prochaines
années il va y avoir directement un rôle
d'une équipe où il donnera des minutes
ce qu'on a pu voir avec l'équipe de
penser que c'était parce qu aurore c'est
pas un mec qui vient pour aider des
paniers c'est pas vraiment un meneur de
jeu c'est un gars qui remonte le ballon
qui est un excellent défenseur sur
l'homme est loin du bas qui est très
propre mais qui a montré des difficultés
aussi bien athlétique que ce qui est 7e
fondamentaux pour pouvoir mettre le
ballon dans le cercle et ça c'est quand
même une des qualités recherchées un
minimum charge voire surtout que
l'unique compétition moi j'ai jamais
rien si un doute mais bon c'est pas ici
tu voir il disait
manuel sur ce parce que tu as vu sur
place
une bonne attitude
effectivement un gars qui rentre et qui
qui est dans son rôle et quand ce qu'on
fait pas trop
exactement c'est un mec comme la bio qui
lie la didacture en tournoi critique le
basket et qu il faut continuer à kiffer
le basket donc c'est simple plus ou
moins un monsieur propre en fait il va
savoir faire les bonnes pâtes qui va pas
faire de vagues là sur le tournoi elle
n'a pas été en réussite au tir ce qui a
qui lui a pas mal valu d'être d'être
bencher notamment contre l'espagne ou
dans le premier quart-temps x10 sur
trois on l'a pas revue du match
il a joué 7 minutes il y fait 0 sur 3 0
sur 4 et est du coup c'est vraiment ça
pour moi après niveau attitude sur le
banc mais sur le terrain ça allait il
tape à fait faisable ouais après faut
voir mais c'est compter sans un joueur
qui à
l'insset top sur way
lookée vous a ajouté sur notre ami théo
moi j'ai beaucoup aimé
t au sur ce sol et sur les flashs qu'on
a vu en sortie de banc
la folie offensive de piétrus est il
qu'en est il il a une bonne vision de
jeu mais je trouve qu'il n'a pas ce côté
où tu où on sent que c'est nature il les
voit les passes
mais il n'y a pas ce il les sent pas il
se tait qu'elle soit là parce qu'il a
travaillé pour apple
il ya dix ans maxime logo en bas de
pagny lumet mais lui mais parce que
c'est c'est évident il à côté voix
remplie manager et filles c'est et c'est
plus ça qui devrait travailler en avis
est ses fulgurances à la passe qui
aiderait à développer son sens de son
jeu
du match il fait ça c'est le système
c'est parce que c'est le système pagnot
mais il a fait ce système maillotine
match où il fait ça mais moi je vois
qu'ils charrient l'a défendu et
apprendra qu'il a fait
si vous n'avez pas l'image sur train de
faire le change mais c'est exactement ce
que j'ai toute la
compagnie a des cornes le fameux cornes
que tout le monde connaît tout tout tout
à chacun qui a joué au basket c'est que
on va faire cornes les deux grands les
deux grands qui vont monter ensuite on
va développer quelque chose un spain où
quelque chose dans le genre
est ce qu'on est ce qui nous manque
quelqu'un bah oui donc le meilleur qu
à non on appelle on n'a pas parlé de la
mare pardon mais lou place le soin non
tension
luca c'est toi qui nous qui nous
présente la mare si si si le ce on veut
bien et on complétera le ce qui manque
et hésitez pas à me couper mais si
jamais elle s'en va
je n'ai
presque pas reconnu quand je les ai vus
jouer
parce que en espoirs et il a un peu ce
côté aussi où il passe inaperçu dans le
jeu offensif
vraiment rentré dans donc pas dans le
jeu offensif tout simplement de pain ont
toute la campagne il a beaucoup plu il a
eu beaucoup plus un rôle défensif c'est
un poste 2-3 athlétique 1 une qualité de
pénétration
c'est plutôt ça pour l'instant son
profil et son profil et sa sa grosse
grosse pitt de développement ce avec le
tir à trois points
je sais plus j'ai noté quelque part il y
là il à 0,6 à trois points sur six ont
été en inventer et aussi sait si c'est
pas fameux donc pour moi c'est sa plus
grosse prise de travail de voir dans la
liste recensant mais mentir
c'est une belle taille
cholet il fait 1 mais 95 il vient de
villemomble si je me trouve blanc mesnil
voilà j'ai de balancier twitter via les
trois ils avaient eu lieu
je suis éternelle en fait mon cas ça
fait 20 ans que j'ai la
une toi tu les aimes bien tu sais que tu
les aimes bien tu les aimes bien jouer
défensivement il est long il est il est
bas il est
discipliné
c'est tout ce que j'ai pour aller les
athlètes qui tire pas assez bien et
qu'il pleut pas c'est bien mais qui sont
athlétiques c'est vraiment ma came après
il avait été décrit comme meneur de jeu
c'est clairement pas un meneur de jeu on
a vu que lui ça sa capacité pour exister
en pro à n'importe quel niveau se
traduire du swing ça va être clairement
servi quand la tribune lundi fou qu'il
tire mais défensivement jeu excepté
peut-être un de nos meilleurs si ce
n'est le meilleur défenseur de ligue sur
l'homme ou loin du ballon par sa
longueur par sa puissance par sa chanson
delande passion
clamart à chaque fois je crois que son
prénom ce numéro 26 là il m'a tapé dans
l'oeil et j'ai envie d'en voir plus qui
dit
il ne dira c'est moins bien que des
ducks - mais bon on dit à gabriel tu
veux tout
parfait
lamarre effectivement on n'y passe pas
des beaucoup de temps puisque puisqu'on
a des joueurs
bas peut-être avec plus de potentiel
parce que l'aller les la mare pichard
même
maloyas qui a mal shooté sur le tournoi
on a parlé beaucoup de troupes et andy
mais qui n'ont pas trop de tri pour
l'instant en tout cas crise l'ont pas
eue sur le tournoi
profil similaire
et là on rentre
alors je l'aimé pas remis on commence
par les arrières de la famille parmi les
arrières
c123 mais qui est porteur de balle il
n'est pas de trés classable pas comme
dadié donc joueur du paris basket
je sais plus qui ferme après ce sétois
manu est ce que tu peux me parler ce
joueur profile donc précise qui a été
blessé pendant pendant une partie du
tournoi pas donc comme tu dis c'est un
poste porteur de balle dos tout moi je
le verrais plus de 3 à terme de deux
mètres que je vous parie basket en
espoir est que jouera normalement
l'eurocup l'année prochaine avec avec le
paris basket ball c'est le c'est
l'objectif du club c'est ce qu'on a
entendu
donc ça va lui permettre de gagner
encore dans son jeu ça va être super
intéressant pour lui et c'est un genre
que pato est en moi je m'attendais à un
peu plus l'ayant déjà vu notamment sur
les ailes à une gêne t où la veille
étaient formidables là où un peu à
l'image de du premier jour donc j'espère
aller donc j'ai oublié non fiegel il a
pas trop réussi à trouver son rôle en
fait il a eu très très peu de tirs il y
avait que 19 tirs sur le surtout le
tournoi en cinq matches mais ça à peine
4 par match mais serra - dignité et que
si trois points donc il met trois sur
trois mais là aussi c'est très compliqué
il fait déjà deux sur deux sur un match
contre la slovénie déjà la moitié de ces
tirs paraître quartier tiercé sur un mac
devrait donc c est ca c'est assez
compliqué et du coup il ya eu la
blessure contre la montre le canada où
il se blesse au poignet droit à son
poignet choot ans ammann a marre de foot
où tout d'abord il a été ils ont mis de
la glace après la été strappé et
lendemain il a vu une attelle et quand
il revient pour les quarts de finale
sont classés venez où il ya incroyable
il est re strappé mais on vraiment on
voyait que c'était vraiment épais qu'il
avait vraiment du mal à tirer en fait
c'était compliqué donc l'espagne c'est
pareil lituanie pareil ou du coup il a
bien plus dans le mali la villa mais il
marque 0 point nice 0 0 sur 4 aux tirs
il marquera lancers francs sur les deux
matches et on sentait qu'il était à 13 %
de ses capacités quoi il pouvait
vraiment rien faire qu'ils pouvaient pas
niable et ne pouvaient pas shooter du
coup bah ils étaient ils étaient juste
sur le terrain histoire de faire le
nombre quoi malheureusement et je pense
que sur ce tournoi là on n'a pas vu le
vrai pas comme l'a dit kéké vraiment en
dessous un vrai bon joueur autrement qui
est capable tu tires et de te faire un
peu de pages d'aller un peu austère
qu'il est encore un peu sauf là dessus
mais ça à terme je pense que ça peut le
faire donc c'est sa blessure vient un
peu le gâcher son tournoi
malheureusement
locale a comme dadiès est peut-être le
gars qui aurait le plus plus joué et
créateurs pour cette équipe de france
u17
parce que par ses qualités évidentes
naturel
ma question pour toi c'est qu'est-ce qui
va travailler maintenant pas condamner
il faut le mettre là il faut le mettre
avec les pros il va jouer l'euro cup il
faut il faut qu'ils aillent il faut
qu'ils aillent cohade qui lie maillot
chez qui avait finir au cercle un peu
plus je pense que ce que en tout cas ce
que moi je t'aimerai bien voir l'année
prochaine avec les pros
intensité j'aimerais bien le voir
remonter la balle
tout ralenti de changer de riz
d'attaquer le cercle
impactant dans ce moment où il a la
balle et je pense qu'il devra forcément
l'être parce qu'il aura pas autant de
baphuon et je pense qu'on a eu qu'un
petit échantillon de caen
l'un des seuls bonne paire sur le
terrain avec loïck landre et qui vers la
fin de saison avec les lentes et
l'envoyer dadou ou plus dans un rôle de
deuxième hollande l'heure qui qui avait
écrit du coup sélectionné beaucoup plus
et tient
bon je pense que on le verra beaucoup
plus l'année prochaine
huguet
merci carte adams qui dit on à capter le
plus important une jeune femme artiste
pas ouais c'était mieux que dallas a
presque tout compris
un peu la collection est une oppression
tendance à l'impression qu'il est dans
une des dans une cave à vin
[Musique]
effectivement une qu'est-ce que tu as
comme dadiès et le pour l'instant de ce
qu'on a parlé c'est le potentiel le plus
tôt
par la créa difficile à dire pourquoi de
si tu le dis si tu l'as vu que le holy
17 mai ouais mais tu va très vite quand
on a regardé le premier match chaud
whatsapp en discuter tout c'est toi et
manzetti a pas comme des 10 il ya un
truc quoi dans la vaccination des
espaces et c'est un des ce qu'il n'y ait
plus qui vous coûte le plus cher alors
il a un physique mais on sait que pour
pas supérieur ce que les équipes vont
regarder à tous les niveaux c'est est ce
que tu es capable de te créer toi même
ton propre retire et c'est un des seuls
de notre équipe qui peut le faire donc
oui clairement c'est un des plus gros
potentiels pour ça parce que tu peux
avoir l'espoir d'avoir un attaquant qui
se suffit à lui même et donc bloquer
tout le reste après ça s'est vraiment
l'excitation de courchamp ce jour là
nous le disait luca pourquoi pas
développer un handled d'abord dans un
rôle secondaire et eon et ensuite de
s'en servir pour effectivement se créer
son tir
en propre le haut niveau on va passer
aux ailiers intérieur messieurs et je
vais commencer
par
luca et diawara
qui
qui était vraiment le couteau suisse
n'en est rien et c'était plutôt 6 dans
cette équipe et il n'a pas eu énormément
d'occasions de briller mais mais c'est
le genre de joueur en si on le regarde
en tant que spectateur du match on ne
voit pas trop et si on le regarde en
tant que ce cas autant on le voit
beaucoup
présentent nous son profil d'abord qui
est il ou joue-t-il quelle taille tout
ça
fait 2 m 05 aux dernières nouvelles
parce qu'il il a l'air d'avoir grandi
encore
les joues à paris c'est un joueur qui
peut jouer les cinq postes qui peut un
peu plus de mal sur le poster un logique
de sa taille mais
c'est vraiment un jour le plus le plus
gros prospects de cette équipe il ya un
jeu un profil voile ballon linge tout à
trois points qui on n'a pas pu le voir
en compétition mais il y en a trois
points
en catch and shoot et c'était rare il
peut aller créer au panier this paper
athlétiquement il peut vraiment apporter
des gorges chaudes des gros les grandes
choses et dès l'année c'est vraiment un
profil intéressant il ya une grande
envergure il peut remonter la balle
c'est
aussi bien cette campagne que dure la
saison cette année
quelque chose à ajouter du côté de man u
bac c'est pour un peu comparé c'est un
peu un moussa diabaté et la version
évoluée de moussa diabaté quoi c'est un
mec qui va pouvoir des fonctions tout le
monde moi je les ai vus prendre l'âme de
yann vidé sur sur le match contre la
slovénie le prenais tout terrain il
voyait plus la balle c'est franchement
il y il ses stats faut les oublier sur
thomas parce que ce qui fait c'est
vraiment impressionnant en fait il est
capable de tout faire
fang quasiment sûr tout le monde qui est
vraiment c'était vraiment leader
défensif de l'équipe avec temps avec
penda on les sentait c'était vraiment
eux qui donnait là l'impulsion à
l'équipe et sur le web capable de tirer
très bon à la passe et c'est également
c'est moi c'est vraiment ce que ce que
j'adore le plus chez lui c'est de le
voir passer il est pas beaucoup d'avoir
moins d'une passes décisives par match
mais parce que le mouvement de l'équipe
de france n'est pas top top mais
autrement il est capable de l'île et
polyvalent la pacifier un peu ce qu'il
veut c'est pas ça demain pas le dire
avec band passe à une main c'est
vraiment impressionnant nettement de le
voir jouer et de mettre 21 d'envergure
ça peut rêver
ah ouais ouais ah c'est beau c'est
beaucoup un pur de 0,5 il être dû
grandir un peu comme s'est beaucoup
donné les informations du du paris
basket ball ouais ok bois peut-être
qu'ils ajoutent un ou deux centimètres
pour faire il jouera en propre avec en
eurocup l'année prochaine son film
babine ce projet pour lui donc on
améliore le tir us qu'on améliore chez
lui ou qu'est-ce qu'on travaille plutôt
est ce que mon ballet de plus est sur du
haendel est ce qu'on va faire un
connecteur qui s'est un peu tout faire
tu vois un gars dont c'est un profil
assez rare aussi un
genre ce genre de profil pour la nba
puisque là on parle de prospects qui
sont clairement un plafond nba où est-ce
qu'on travaille plus le tir ce qu'on
travaille un peu de tout ça c'est quoi
ton avis là dessus
je fais tout à une réponse qui va
peut-être un peu facile mais un peu tout
ça va
davantage de jouer à paris qu' une
équipe qui veut envoyer avec wyeth et
qui ont déjà beaucoup le lie avec des
maîtres soit par l'organisation mais
aussi parce qu'ils ont relevés gars qui
va est ratée par les celtics parce
qu'ils on espère kamagaté maintenant on
est gâté cetera dont ils auront des
retours sur qu'est ce qui te plaît ou
non chez jaguar a et syd équipe prend 1
bollène l'heure je pense qu'ils vont
tout miser sur lui donne la balle ces
équipes voient plutôt un finisseur on va
pure du catch and shoot voiture du pick
and pop on va toujours de la transition
tintin physique tu as vraiment tout
basketteur
va falloir être spécialisé kelkoo en
fonction de ce que les nba voix et je
pense que je l'aï là le bon contexte
pour pouvoir faire ça hockey
locale dit qu'il était le meilleur
prospect de l'équipe est-ce que hughes
et manu sont d'accord
honnêtement je suis pas vendre le plan
fibre
pour moi non mais et peut-être un des
plus gros potentiel mais pour moi non
mais après c'est aussi c'est parce que
ce que je lis et c'est pas forcément la
réalité nba c'est pas le on parle le
plus en général et même les mecs qui
sont des liens avec un peu de nba même
si arras du twitter voilà c'est pas le
nom qu'on retrouve le plus jawhar mais
il est alors qu'il n'est pas trop connu
encore non ils l ont crié quand il était
à patra que personne ne connaissait
voile et jalal
une tumeur qui doit comme ça on avance
il ya un joueur compte non pas mal n'est
ce pas parce que je sais à moi qui étais
tu vas courir l'eau mais non qu'on
retrouve le plus et saccagé de tâches et
qui pour moi est le joueur le plus mis
en avant et non ni le plus de noms en
dehors du fait que ce soit le fils de
mais pour les équipes nba c'est un
joueur qui est déjà
pas à cary visage et c'est le fils de
stephen reid qui a fait les malheurs de
notre championnat et en équipe de france
c'est un ailier qui fait alors je vais
prendre les mensurations et je remette
mais lui la justice de m 03 il ya 17 ans
et joue avec velde on dans l'équipe de
jeunes de l'asvel c'est un métier très
très
j'ai pas l'envergure peut-être qu'il
aurait pu qu'il a plus son travail mais
il ya il a des très très long et s'est
montré très long c'est un joueur qui
aime cas pas très bien tiré pas moins
derrière la ligne à trois points dans le
tournoi u17 mais qui recoupent pour sa
qualité de tir est effectivement pour
l'avoir plus l'agent de l'eau ombre est
plusieurs fois qui est un excellent
tireur est ce vous sentir qu'il va très
très vite grosbill basket toujours très
bien placé c'est pas un acte dans la
puissance physique on va développer
peut-être un peu là dessus pour le
moment assez à 6 kraz en mai sa science
du placement et sa longueur de temps
font vraiment un prospect très très
intéressant peut-être sa limite
actuellement
c'est que même si on en parle beaucoup
le projet comme un bon rôle player en
nba et qu'il n'a pas cette capacité à se
créer son propre tir pour être un joueur
ce temps là où diarra ou des parfois
maloyas ou des fibres et cetera où on a
vu avec dadié on sait ce style là qu'ils
peuvent peut-être développé par manque
de puissance plus que par manque de
technique nul j'aime beaucoup son
dribble invalides s'est il tire pas
excessivement bien mais qu'on regarde
pas ce contre la lituanie on voit un mec
qui peut changer demain tu peux changer
de rythme changer de vitesse une
farouche opposition mais il ya un manque
effectivement de capacités tu vois cette
step by step
derrière l'écran on n'a pas trop vu
faire ça et effectivement qu'ils
entendent depuis sont n'est pas et pas
assez près mais je me doute que ça se
développe pour ce corps là il est très
très jeune il est très très faim
alors là une des critiques qui est
revenu quand même manu c'est soft
est ce que il il a fait est-ce que c'est
tout le temps comme ça est ce que non
c'est vrai il a subi ces contacts
notamment face à l'espagne mon père mais
pas que
ouais moi c'est ce qu'il fait je sais
pas si c'est un reproche sais pas si
c'est vraiment on peut appeler ça soft
mais c'est qui va pour moi il est trop
engluée dans un rôle de flûte heures à
trois points et je pense qu'il faut
qu'il apprenne à être beaucoup plus que
ça parce qu'il peut être beaucoup plus
que ça on l'a vu sur trop peu de flash
mais on l'a vu prendre la balle est
vraiment qu'ils resserrent clé finir sur
sur du dunk
le des fois il est un peu d rivers qui
rentrait pas donc c'est encore autre
chose mais moi c'est vraiment ça saab
sont le palier qui doit franchir ce
seuil et se mettre dans la tête qu'il
est plus qu'un shooter et qui peut aller
au cirque moi je suis pas forcément
d'accord avec peut se créer son tir
honnêtement alors là pas forcément vu
parce que encore une fois un rôle pas
forcément établi je pense qu'ils disent
à tout le monde mais je pense en fait on
avait trop talent de vrais talents et du
coup c'est un peu fouillis qu'en terme
de personnes avaient un vrai rôle établi
de dans un 5 personne n'avait de rôles
savoir quoi faire sur le terrain
entièrement fouillé mais il peut créer
son tir
il peut tirer de loin et qui tirait en
poule up à mi distance il peut aller au
cirque quand il veut il peut être
extrêmement bons défenseurs moi je
trouve il peut se fier sur les petits
peut défendre sur des quatre sur
certains cas qu'il peut
franchement moi je sais mon un bill dans
les meilleurs des potentiels procès de
l'équipe parce que je compte pas ça
parce que je ne connais pas assez élevé
puisque sur ce tournoi là donc on en
parlera après mais c'est
voilà soft pour revenir à la question de
badges je sais pas si on peut qualifier
ça t-shirt en fait
j'essaie vraiment le terme je pense moi
qu'il est surtout calibré dans un rôle
de flotteurs et c'est à dire en la
personne de l'écran mais peut-être que
tu l'a ressentie différemment c'est
aussi un manque de combativité tu vois
et c'est ce qu'on va chercher chez les
ch et les grands joueurs chez les
joueurs qui vont terminer procès c'est
ce mental dur au mal et c est encore une
fois son dès 2005 on a le temps de
développer et les qualités physiques et
la dureté mentale mais
c'est des choses qui sont quand même
généralement marquée dans l'adn aussi le
fait est ce que est ce que je vais
accepter de sacrifier mon corps est ce
que je vais
face à l'adversité me prendre en main et
et le fait est qu'il a peu su le faire
il l'a fait mais il l'a fait grâce à
dadié pour moi en quarts de finale
dadié insuffle une dynamique et ensuite
risager
roule sur le match clairement
mais mais en bas en demi puis mais même
même fait enfin il doit être pour moi il
doit pas être notre meilleur joueur
offensif et il n'est pas
d'accord sur
le côté
je suis pas trop d'accord avec toi parce
que
manuel à vue
on l'a pas vue sur cette campagne
mais est à belgrade à deux blessés quoi
promis le deuxième match il y avait un
match compliqué à aller jouer juste
après était un peu on se posait la
question avec cavani coma nuances des
skis pas où est ce qu'il va laisser
faire mal à les prendre même s'il a
martelé sermat pour les prendre ces tirs
etc et il est prêt il a tenu tout le
tournoi blessé et c'est ce que sa
personnalité
et il n'est pas ici jamais crier et
après à l'avant le mien trois points et
justement cette de pro ou
ti pour lee et qu'il faut y aller il y a
mais c'est intéressant d'avoir d'autres
contextes aussi là on parle de bilan
hall 17 mais évidemment il ya d'autres
contextes et c'est intéressant de savoir
voilà qui là qu'il a montré d'autres
choses qu'est ce qu'on développe chez
chea carisa chez
haendel est ce qu'on lui donne à manger
beaucoup ouais
tu tu rajoutes tu envoies américaine au
nom s ici est derrière tout grand joueur
quoi c'est
parti de jeter qui va pas trop au sax
douche ensuite forcée qui sait que s'il
veut réussir pour l'instant il est trop
au point qu'il a pu se faire démonter
et que lorsqu'il va amener un peu de
masse il va plus offrir des espaces et y
aller parce qu'il a le dribble il a en
réalité le tir il a donc là il fait quoi
il a chois qu'il a deux lancers francs
sur la compétition c'est trop et il
faudra apparemment vous gagnez la masse
musculaire vrai
c'est ça ben on va dire que c'est la
principale piste de travail et nous
reste quelques joueurs a évoqué et pas
des moindres
je vais enchaîner avec celui que tu as
évoqué toi manu puisqu'il s'agit de
alexandre sarr alors vas-y présente nos
profils il joue en overtime élite
l'immense overtime élites et nos
petits jouent avec les futurs l'autre
des pics jumeaux thompson il était un
des plus jeunes joueurs de wertheim
élite cette année donc c'est un 2005 et
maintenant quel profil physique un peu
dans le jeu de ce que tu as vu sur ses
u17
moi je le qualifierais post 4 voire 5
annoncée à 2 13
vraiment super mobile fluide
l'envergure gelé pas mais à vue n'est
elle est l apal est supérieure à sa
taille donc elle est positive et c'est
un joueur de ce que j'ai vu sur chaque
match il prouvait qu'il pouvait faire
autre chose au début on l'a vu vraiment
limité on ne savait pas trop quoi faire
ils prenaient pas beaucoup de tirs le
match d'après commencent à s'écarter
attire cakin shoot à trois points le
match d'après y commence à faire des
pommes sec dans la dans la dans la
raquette et terminer avec un finger roll
il est toujours ajouter quelque chose
capable après deux sur match suivant de
défendre sur du 1 à 4 de ses essais
c'était vraiment impressionnant de le
voir évoluer sur eux petit à petit sur
sur les matches
c'est moi je vais attendre un peu plus
l'un d'eux peut-être un peu de
protection de cercle à un peu plus d'un
contre par match mais je pense qu'il
peut faire plus que ça peut-être à terme
un espèce de stretch 5 stratfor sait pas
trop encore comment le
l'utiliser mais ces poches intérieures
sur entre les deux et c'est franchement
je le connaissais pas du tout on m'a
souvent dit qu'il était on va pas en
parler souvent quand je parle qu'on
parlait d'olivier on m'a toujours dit il
y tient un peu meilleur que son frère
et sur ce que j'ai vu là sur le tournoi
je suis assez d'accord je n'ai pas été
déçu il est surtout plus mozilla avait
déjà montré face à des athlètes parce
qu'on on peut critiquer à raison le ce
que propose le var times et l'iht
parfois mais mais il ya des vrais
athlètes prospects futur prospère
billets et pour le coup il switch
quasiment sûr tout le monde en dollars
tels militent
donc eu pour pour les pistes de travail
pour pour alexandre ça on va prendre du
gap c'est pareil on va prendre du poids
quand même pour pouvoir tenir un peu le
le le contact quand on vit à aider aux
contres pour pas se faire envoyer dans
les balustrades ma boîte aux lettres le
nutritionniste dopage de l'équipe meiway
lamastre pour pouvoir mieux encaisser je
suis trouvée c'est toujours chiant de
comparer avec son trait est serré mais
il est plus dans le jeu peut attaquer
panier qu'olivier qui était vraiment
fait ce tweet on l'avait vu à kentucky
mon année compliquée mais voilà il peut
poser le ballon manon va falloir
vraiment on va prendre de la masse tu
s'épaissir pour être un second rideau
défensif intel et après ça va le faire
mais très impressionné par alexandre
jardin dans le skills est proposée par
le jeune francilien
vrai tir intéressant va falloir
s'appliquer un peu aux lancers francs je
monte c'est valable pour toute l'équipe
donc donc pour la pub pour l'année et
l'année prochaine c'est pas sûr dit manu
key restant en overtime élite on va
suivre le dossier
mais en tout cas peut-être qu'ils
rendent universitaire peut-être mais en
tout cas voilà les pistes de travail
sont là il ya du foot il ya du même de
la passe
sinon moment dans mon équipe locale dira
pas renié un besoin poste 5 qui peut
venir jouer c'est le niveau sympa moi je
vous le dimanche matin une fois par mois
il peut quitter le dépanner
si tu as it had et des bancs de
protéines a proposé aux six
sélectionnés on fera ça
exactement
luca je sais que tu dois y aller donc
présentement rapide non notre ami
jacques qui était le joueur le plus
grand de l'équipe c'était ça
et sonne à 2015
donc qu'est-ce que ça en fait planche
très honorée de présenter votre chouchou
au début je me suis dit c'est un
prospect biais
puis appris j'ai regardé les matches
j'ai vite compris que tout tient ce 1
500 rôles school
bailly mais l'équipe se donne il hurle
il se fait des boule à zéro parce qu'il
va à la guerre et donc c'est un peu un
héros
mais
ont des écrans retard
fer fédéraux ils posent énormément
d'écran je pense que par voie iv est
impressionnant le tout le travail qu qui
qu'il apporta assez keeper qui avait
vraiment un rôle qui avait un rôle
défini ou pas mais est ce qu'ils
allaient faire prendre des robes
poser des écrans il a fait un beau
bateau s'est levé celui qui a eu le plus
beau le plus
le plus positif a fait un vrai un batave
contre l'espagne est sa principale puis
de travail c'est le tir ministre il
développe un tir à mi distance heures
plus encore plus hot sas a pas de
carbone pour la suite
parfait merci luca je te laisse y aller
pendant que l'on termine bref ça va
bientôt et de toute façon tous les
joueurs dont on parle vous allez
retrouver des scouts in report sur la
compétition écrit sur notre site au fur
et à mesure des prochaines semaines donc
voilà vous retrouverez notamment la plus
de luca a plus ou cas
à plus je vous laisse entre micro ondes
bah oui finalement il nous manque pas
grand monde on finira avec avec noah
penda mais on va parler d'eux c'était
maxime louguet
loeb le bilan tourne au
pied mais sans sa star de maxime
attention maxime ce qu'on veut
c'est toi qui le présente hugo notre ami
lomé donc plus on dort size les plus
costauds le numéro 20 de rien voilà des
équipes de france c'est ça alors joueur
jours les plus jeunes de l'équipe n'a
que 16 ans maxi ok bah ouais j'avais 17
ans et tu vois pas grand chose il fait 2
m 3 c'est pareil c'est notre notre poule
france est un
il est considéré comme lié fort pivot il
a joué très très peu en fait chaud de
compétition n'a pas énormément de choses
à dire jean maxime louguet parce qu'il
était là vraiment 3e troisième rotation
intérieure derrière jacques et sarthe on
a vu un beau bestiaux physique est
quelqu'un qui a une bonne détente sèche
avec un plat du pied pour monter qui a
l'air déjà très physiquement par rapport
aux autres mecs mais on n'a pas vu un
mec qui bénéficier en tout cas qu'ils
prenaient l'avantagé de cette avance
physique pro 2000 et voilà on a une
finition près du panier assez aléatoire
il pour le coup lui a très très peu de
jeu
autant le périmètre voilà c est
reproduit assez assez brute à c'est fini
on va mettre des écrans va rouler on va
de nous et on va essayer de prendre des
rebonds mais voilà donc un tout petit
rôle et je sais pas c'est année
prochaine il reste ou paul peut-être du
mal et
puis il faut
un peu plus mais il joue 4 5 minutes par
match et joue même pas le dernier match
no
way explosivité sur les petits espaces
c'est un peu un peu à la manière des
piliers de rugby même si les plus grands
qu'un pilier ben rubi on va terminer et
puis pourrait mais il est peut-être trop
branche pense plus deuxième ligne
on va terminer avec un autre joueur qui
est plutôt fini physiquement je pense
en tout cas cependant dans la carrure
c'est seynois penda donc qui jouait au
pôle france cette année qui l'année
prochaine sera à vichy clermont
c'est à lui c'est ça on man u bad beat
là on salue évidemment
guillot visa d'
le coach
manu présente nous quel joueur et noah
penda
alors que nos appels de ses postes
quatre cas annoncés à deux mètres 0-2
donc c'est un joueur que moi parce que
j'adore particulièrement c'est un de mes
chouchous il est pas forcément
je sais pas si on peut forcément le
comptabiliser comme un prospect billets
mais c'est un joueur qui est très
intelligent
notamment en défense où honnêtement il y
est il est actif tout le temps il parle
beaucoup il sait toujours où se placer
il a toujours eu une seconde avant ce je
me rappelle d'un match ou contre rennes
urbex d'aller voir ou contre attaque qui
vous il va pour le pour sauter sauf
qu'ils voient que le de l'attaquant
regarde il fait sa fin du coup il saute
pas est il comptera près c'est vraiment
le sien c'est un peu l'action qui qui
peut le définir en fait c'est un gars
qui est très très intelligente pic
beaucoup de ballons sur le tournoi il
est plus de plus de deux interceptions
par match sur le tournage c'est vraiment
j'ai pas son envergure on va mais il est
long
mais il est difficile
à des hyper londres à la c
est lui aussi blessé sur le tournoi
contre le japon il se
fait la cheville donc il a manqué le
quart de finale contre la slovénie
revenus contre l'espagne et la lituanie
où vous voulez pas loin d'être le
meilleur malgré une fille 50% et c'est
une des qualités chez lui c'est comme il
est quatre mais il est ultra mobile
comme assez mobile et du coup il ya
beaucoup de milles ce match et ce à
l'aide a créé sont un peu d'espacé aller
vers le faire qu'il a eu pas mal de fois
mara comme ça là l'intérieur espagnol
qui fait 2 15 et il a créé beaucoup de
poids comme ça en allant en dribblant
est alors vers le cercle c'est un joueur
aussi qui peut foutais un peu c'est pas
forcément sa qualité premier army à
terme je pense qu'il pourra shooter
notamment en catch and shoot à trois
points pas trop dans la création encore
des espaces pour sentir mais ça sert pas
foule était là qu'on peut appeler un son
que le considérer comme un intrus angie
mais il ya quelque chose dit pour
l'instant il a plus le dit que le fruit
comme beaucoup de des joueurs qu'on a
parlé mais j'ai un mec kof je pense on
l'a vu discuter en espagne entre nous
pour moi c'est lui le l'un des joueurs
qui aura la meilleure carrière de tous
les jours on a chip coeur
parce qu'il ya cette intelligence cet
instinct aussi c'est ça ouais c'est ça
et si
j'ai du mal à le voir en nba mais je
pense que c'est un gars que règne la
carrière en euroligue l'image d'un
bandeau de colo n'a pas forcément réussi
elle s'est elle même profil mais oui oui
mais en termes de carrière je pense que
je le vois bien être un genre dominant
en euroligue à terme en fait et avoir
une vraie carrière
hugues qu'est ce que tu as ajouté sur ce
qu'a dit manu sur noah penda
c'est le nom sur le bon poids ça pourra
comparer tout ça tape tonnes de coeur
c'est drôle parce qu'on en a on s'est
tous fait la route individuellement et
en 7 septembre il retint pas été dit bah
ouais c'est exactement ce qu'on pensait
le titre alors on pouvait pour le kopa
qui mangent qu'après sinon il est plus
large que aux locaux mais peu qu'ils
puissent tirer il est sur la compétition
il fallait voir deux buts à 3 points
donc un tout petit volume et aux lancers
francs 2 % donc ça va être pour lui une
cliente et pour le niveau supérieur que
ce soit en ces espagnols pic ou
peut-être lié même si effectivement
c'est pas un semble pas pis la plus
évidente produit
et ça va être très intéressant pour le
coup on est quand même hyper content de
voir que du prospect a choisi vichy
aller jouer en pro b c en pro b oui se
monte à maurice allais pas les jouer on
allait jouer en pro b face il ya quand
même des baux bestiaux
sur les postes 3 4 donc ça va être très
intéressant de le voir dans la
difficulté dans la difficulté dans
l'adversité physiques en tout cas et
voir si larry va toujours à se créer des
points en tout cas en nationale une il
était il a été efficace cette année au
pôle france donc à voir si en montant
d'un cran en il le sera toujours en tout
cas on est très content de le voir faire
ce choix manu
je t'entends pas la couper 1 est ce que
tu as quelque chose à ajouter
manu toi qui étais là bas sur l'attitude
est ce qu'il ya un joueur qui l'a
particulièrement marqué dans la
sa positive attitude comme disait jean
pierre raffarin est nourrie
bas c'était pas un endettement non c'est
pas le latitude a été assez moyenne nous
on a entendu dire que il avait des des
choses en tête qui pas des missions mais
à toi tu parles de penda moi je parlais
en général mais vas-y peu sa part dont
ben du coup elles peuvent continuer les
il était un peu dans il y avait des
objectifs en tête qui n'a pas forcément
a atteint et du coup des fois il avait
un peu des mouvements d'humeur
donc c'est peut-être
ça aussi à revoir choses sur le terrain
ou en dehors sur le banc aussi des
volcans se charger ouais ok
gros gros compétiteur gros en cas un bon
caractère on va pas dire voilà vingt
gagnants quais
et sur le reste de l'équipe s'il ya
quelque chose qui t'a marqué dans le off
off courte en tout cas ce qu'on voyait
pas que ce soit les échauffements
les attitudes qui vous revenez
en termes d'attitude non j'ai pas là
rien qui m'a sauté aux yeux c'est plus
du voile aile et des joueurs qui ont
attiré l'oeil de sûr notamment
d'université mais pas mal à malaga ou
non notamment quoi ya deux noms qui sont
revenus à nos oreilles et qui ont attiré
c'est plus ça quand ils voient attitude
assez déchus de leur dû du manque
d'entrain sur la médaille de bronze je
pense qu'ils étaient assez déçus d'être
sortis par l'espagne où ils peuvent
clairement gagné le match et du coup que
face à l'espagne quand il peint que face
à la lituanie n'y a pas eu d'effusion de
joie n'y a pas eu même après quand ils
reçoivent leur médaille après le après
la finale on y est a énormément de
sourire quoi les styles étaient plus
déçu par la suite il visait clairement
plus il avait autre chose en tête que la
médaille de bronze donc on n'en saura
jamais que ses bureaux ni c'est que 24
heures après
ouais ouais puis je pense qu'il avait
envie de taper méric ainsi
charles aura des américains 1 vas-y
vas-y
voix non je voulais juste avoir parce
que juste en regardant les matchs à
l'extérieur c'était tactiquement on des
fois alors après je tu vas y que je te
dis mais vas-y ghm et moi un mec ou
mieux de cette zone et que c'est pas est
ce que tu avais des joueurs qui eux qui
prêtent n'est pas là dessus qu'ils
disaient vas-y on changea ou même entamé
un groupe de gamins qui écoutait
vraiment le staff et c'était les coaches
les plus importants moi j'aime bien tu
vas savoir ce qu'il dit est amené stop
ça marche pas venez montant de ce
nom j'ai pas plus sur la défense
ccp n'diaye diawara on sentait vraiment
que c'était les leaders il parlait
beaucoup il était vraiment dans la
gestuelle dans les consignes pour les
autres et c'est vraiment poussé ces deux
noms après offensivement
j'ai pas vu un gars un peu secoué tout
le monde ment malheureusement les bases
de ce qui a manqué
il manquait un manque est un gars calais
qui avait secoué va le kaki que les
espagnols avaient d'ailleurs l'honneur
espagnol j'ai perdu son nom conrad
marqué exactement conrad sauvé les
esprits plus exactement ils ont toujours
des mecs comme ça
on était déçu mais écoutez une troisième
place
l'espagne avait plein de crosse paie
aussi les américains aussi on frappe
installe dans d'autres bilans oui bah on
craint une émission spéciale usa et une
autre émission reste du monde ce qui
avait aussi les prospects sympa
australie lituanie serbie également
j'ai plongé nié avec vide et donc voila
c'était il ya des choses à dire encore
sur cette coupe du monde u-17 vous
pouvez suivre celle des filles
qui sont en quarts de finale quel jour
on si je ne m'abuse soit demain soit
prêt demain donc voilà les filles coupe
du monde u17 1 à voir si elles vont si
elles vont arriver au moins en demi
finale voire faire mieux québec merci
manu merci hugues
hugues vendredi un stream ou pas
si ma fille fait ses nuits oui
c est le facteur des pampres
actuellement le facteur historique
c'est le facteur coliques
[Musique]
encore quelques semaines normalement
je pense quelques années je suis pour
les nuits normalement il ya quelques
semaines suffiront
soutien de sa mère non
mais c'est un autre débat messieurs et
j'ai un couteau sous la gorge qui
m'attend juste porte je vais calmer mais
terme maintenant ok si hugues est vivant
et que sa fille dort vous avez le droit
à un stream vendredi sur twitter abonnez
vous sur youtube et sur twitch à votre
niveau de chaîne et pour recevoir les
notifs quand on fait un live ou quand on
sort une nouvelle vidéo salut les gars
disent ouf